[Music]
[Applause]
right uh let's bring in Chase Daniel
former NFL quarterback and host of The
Chase Daniel show on YouTube channel you
always learn something he always makes
us smarter when we talk to him uh thanks
for joining us chase explain to me how
rookie receivers are having this kind of
impact like puka nakua you know Cooper
cup
like those guys are out of nowhere then
you had obj when he came in you have
Jamar Chase and Justin
Jefferson I like is this going to be
normal or is this an aberration in your
mind this is definitely not normal
especially with puka and you look at
puka and you look at Cooper and what's
the one person holding them together
Matthew Stafford and Matthew Stafford is
absolutely balling right like they
brought in pukah and when cup was hurt
at the beginning of the year they said
hey just go be Cooper cup like doesn't
seem that hard to do when you're in that
offense but it's extremely hard the
dude's got more 150 yard scrimmage games
than anyone ever in the National
Football Le League including you know
Randy Moss Jamar Chase all these guys
and it's pretty impressive for me to to
like what puka has been able to do
because he doesn't look very fast he's a
strong son of a buck he's 220 pounds he
they give him like jet sweeps the guy
like last night hit him and just fell
off of him and on the game-winning like
Jet Sweep like it's he's made different
and so you just really never know what
you're getting when you're drafting a
rookie receiver like like look at
Quinton Johnson in the Chargers like
hasn't really lived up to the hype of
the first round pick and you know they
got puka in the fifth round and quite
honestly he's he's really close in my
opinion to to winning Rookie of the Year
between it's between him and CJ strad
right it's probably a Quarterback Award
probably G to go to CJ St but it needs
to be talked about on what puka is doing
and then you look at just Matthew
Stafford like when you have a guy like
that and you're able to go in and you're
able to have puka learn under Matthew
which Matthew's been you know on on like
everywhere like my my year 15 years in
the league and probably playing some of
his best ball so you put that and you
put kyen Williams with the Rams offense
like the the coaching job that that um
you know sha mcvey's done this year has
been pretty impressive too but I know
that they just sort of became dangerous
now because they're 8 and seven uh you
know if they get into the playoffs so
let's look at the Rams you know bigger
picture here are they are they going to
make the playoffs and if they do how
dangerous can they be yeah I mean that's
a great question I tweeted that last
night I said two teams that aren't in
the playoffs right now this is before
the game that are going to be really
dangerous is the bills which they don't
even control their own destiny which is
wild to me like if the Rams win out I
think they're going to get in but
they're probably the only team that can
contend with the 49ers in my opinion um
in the playoffs like they're just built
that way you love Shawn McBay but yeah
it's it's probably one of Shawn mcb's
most impressive coaching jobs and
everyone's like well he's eight and
seven yeah but you remember that whole
narrative at the beginning of the year
how young they were receiver and Matthew
and no draft came out no draft picks and
Matthew's wife came out and was like a
he has a hard time like understanding
the young guys well it's working right
now like they came off by they're five
and one like that seems so long ago to
me
and it's just impressive like like you
know obviously everyone knows the stats
but with kyen Williams they're averaging
14.7 points per game without kir
Williams with kyen Williams 28 points a
game so like that fact that they're
running the ball I mean I saw a stat
last night Dan that they pre- snapped
motioned or shift on
90% of the snaps in the uh game last
night which would be the third highest
rate in in NFL history 90% your motion
your shifting your that's sort of how we
Blitz the defense and the fact that all
these young guys have sort of worked up
to this point and Shan McBay trusted
them like these guys got to be smart to
run that offense that's with puka too
like there's so many little option
routes there's so many different routes
that he has three to four options to do
and they're all on the same page they're
clicking right now their defense is
playing well but honestly like that
offense is is the one that is has them
roll it okay concerns you about the
49ers
nothing like if I'm being honest like I
break him down every week because I'm a
see that that that makes me nervous that
that there's no
flaws like so they're going to the Super
Bowl if I said you could have the ners
of the field in the NFC and I was and I
was a big ners fan even when they were
going through that three- game losing
strength because I like it it to the
Rams when they went with Matthew
Stafford when they had that little
midseason collapse and then all of a
sudden it made made him stronger and
they ended up pushing through and going
through um look I mean on offense they
just they don't really have like they
don't have a weakness man like I I've
it's really hard like the only team and
I say this about a few teams the only
team that can beat the 49ers are the
49ers like penalties um illegal
formation penalties like stuff like that
like their defense was struggling a
little bit they finally it seems like
they've sort of shrunk their menu on
defense and so they're playing a lot
faster they're not doing a whole bunch
of this other coverages and stuff like
they were doing before Dallas when
Dallas came in and and whooped like all
that stuff is sort of out the window and
they're just they're just tackling well
man they're they're uh they're really
impressive it's it's hard to find a
weakness for those guys but I'm
wondering is the Team
MVP the same as the league MVP if I said
who is the MVP of the
ners yeah of the ners at CMC it's not
even close but as you know Dan it's a
Quarterback Award for the NFL so Brock
pie is far and away like numbers-wise
he's won in every single category but
like CMC 20 plus touchdowns like does
CMC in like deserve the credit yeah but
like when was the last running back to
win the MVP was it leanian Tomlinson or
who was it Adrian Peterson AP yeah so
it's just like it's built this League's
built on quarterback play and the fact
that mystery relevant is playing like an
MVP like that's that's a story in it of
its own self so I love Brock I think
Brock's doing really good right now but
it feels like with Brock pie if he was a
first round draft pick no one would have
a problem with him being an MVP it was
he's Mr Irrelevant it feels like this is
kind of a novel it's a cute little story
he wins because he's surrounded by
Talent uh which isn't fair to him and no
and then now you have Tua saying hey I'm
keeping receipts because people don't
think that I can I'm not a good
quarterback without Tyreek Hill and moer
and jayen wo yeah it's wild I mean like
when you Ro when you like break down
Brock though some some people and the
narrative sometimes with people that
actually don't know what they're talking
about and just want to throw stuff out
oh this guy's a dink and dunk
quarterback okay
Dan I get so angry about that because
okay they are
32nd in the NFL in passing attempts they
are second in passing yardage the dude
all he does is throw the ball down the
field and yeah okay you're to get a
couple of these screens to Debo or CMC
that go for 60 and it'll pader stat sure
you still got to make the right decision
that's a very intricate offense for for
a quarterback to run and he's constantly
like all these layered throws like over
linebackers between safeties and
linebackers they're difficult to do all
these throws are 15 to 20 yards down the
field I saw a back shoulder throw that
he that he had to Debo uh last week
against Arizona to the field opposite
hash perfect throw 35 yards on a DOT
people are like well he doesn't have the
arm strring what do you want what else
do you want him to do that's that's to
me is like drives me crazy because the
Dude is having an absolutely
unbelievable season and deserves all the
credit in the world for it he's chased
Daniel former NFL quarterback and uh you
can watch him on the Chase Daniel show
on YouTube channel which I did and you
were talking about Dak Prescott and his
performance against the Buffalo Bills
let me make this a little bit broader
with the Dallas Cowboys who have Miami
coming up this weekend were you more
concerned with that defense and what it
was unable to do against Buffalo or the
offense that was unable to do anything
against that defense both both and I'll
give you a reason why is because I think
that people have found because if you go
back to week two or three when Dallas
played Arizona Arizona ran the piss out
of the ball like 180 yards rushing beat
them there and then they go and do the
same thing Buffalo does and that's
really just Joe Brady on the offensive
coordinator the new offensive
coordinator for the bills like
completely switching up what the bills
want to be on offense like they are
power football now they're making Josh
Allen not make the big mistake you can
still play Hero Ball but those those
cowboys they haven't they haven't
stopped the run and that's sort of their
biggest problem for me on the defensive
side of the ball but when you go to the
offensive side of the ball I've tried
for three weeks now to understand and to
break down why the Cowboys are averaging
40 points at home and there're 7 and0
and why they're averaging 25 points a
game 24 points a game on the road and
are three and four and I can't for the
life of me I can't understand it it
looks like their offense is completely
different and everyone wants to talk all
the noise and there's less Mo okay none
no you still have to go out and execute
so I'm a little bit worried about that
they go on the road again this week in
Miami it's a must win for Dallas like if
Dallas wants any chance at potentially
potentially getting a onc which I don't
think they can because I think San
Francisco's going to win out like they
gota they gotta have this game but it's
a huge game for Miami too I just don't
know if Miami's beat anyone that I trust
obviously that loss a couple weeks ago
to Tennessee was really telling um and
it's GNA be it's going to be an
interesting game like I just I want to
see Dak and the boys go out and hang 40
on on Vic fio and and the Dolphins which
I don't I don't know if they're going to
end up doing but it's almost like a
getright game even though you're playing
a 10 and4 team if that makes sense
you'll know this language I was told by
a former quarterback and I was saying
you know what's Buffalo doing with
Dallas in real time and he was talking
about two high safeties and and and so
Dak wasn't getting any I mean he was
completing passes decent percentage but
no yards downfield so can you translate
that to me and the audience yeah that's
sha MC der's favorite thing to do and
he's done it his his entire career is he
plays two high safeties and they play
this quarters look so you could possibly
get seven to eight guys in the Box uh
with those quarters safeties who are
playing at like eight to 10 yards which
is wild like if you look at Dallas they
they had a play action shot to Cooks
second play of the game versus quarter
safeties he missed it like the game
might be a lot different okay so they're
not only are they getting you know seven
eight into coverage when passing Downs
are happening but they're getting eight
in the box when running Downs are
happening so it's the best of both
worlds Dallas had I didn't love Dallas's
plan because they were like big block
them up shots two man routes versus two
high safeties just not very good and
they're Manning these guys up underneath
um it's it's an impressive job I mean
you look at Buffalo in every category
they're top six in the NFL and defense
no one talks about it especially with
all the injuries they had up front AJ
esposa was out michah Hyde was out all
these guys have been out and for for
them to sort of flip the switch on who
they are as a team in Buffalo when you
go from a switch at dorsy to Brady at
offensive coordinator they they were
throwing the ball a lot now they're
running the ball like a ton they're keep
it they're playing keep away they're
playing good defense their defense
didn't play in as many snaps because
they playing keepo on offense it's
really complimentary football right now
in Buffalo feels like people are maybe
easing off the Lions
bandwagon why is that yeah I mean are
you still on the line bandwagon okay not
me yeah I mean I I love what go was able
to do especially last game against
Denver five touchdown passes and it just
it if you play them at night like
they're a hard out they're four five
and0 it's like the Lions after dark is
what Jared C said I thought that was so
funny um and it's just an interesting
thing it's really their defense that's
been letting them down offensively
they've been scoring a lot of of points
really the whole year and if you look at
the first really eight games of the year
on defense they were really good under
Aaron Glenn and lately they've been
trying to play a little bit more man
coverage and they've been getting
exposed and so not only that but then
teams are running the ball a lot more
against the Detroit Lions limiting the
possessions that Jared gof has on
offense and those four game stretch
there was a four game stretch where I
think they went two and two golf had
nine turnovers right so no turnovers
last game the previous four he had nine
so just a lot less possessions on
offense so I think if they can handle
the football uh sh up that run defense
and I think they're gonna I mean look
they're going for an NFC North title for
the first time in 30 years like how are
you off the bandwagon it's the Detroit
Lions they haven't been good in forever
I'm excited about it okay before I let
you go let's say I go to a holiday party
and I want to sound like I know what
quarterbacks know like something that
some quarterback jargon that I could be
talking about where people go damn all
right he's not just a talking hairo like
so when you're talking to you know Drew
Brees like can you give me something
where I could just be bringing this up
in a casual way and then you know guys
in the neighborhood are going to go all
right all right he knows what he's
talking about well first of all I love
the sweater so you wear that sweater
you're going to look like you know what
you're talking about with quarterbacking
okay so that's the first and foremost
but I think in in uh in quarterback talk
we talk uh like talk about cadences like
hey going on one going two going three
so like all these cadences I think it's
funny and a lot of teams are using it if
you listen it's like okay on first sound
it's Sunday it's used days of the week
on Monday you go on one so it's ready
blue 80 BL do Tuesday it's two Wednesday
it's three so say yeah did you see Jared
gofman he's going on Tuesday out there
you're wearing that sweater man you're
Mak you're good you're good yeah okay so
so the if it's on
Sunday it's like that it's just like the
first sound so said Hut and Monday is
ready blue 80 blue said Hut it's like on
one and then Tuesday's two Wednesday's
three so give me give me a wed give me a
Wednesday ready blue 80 BL it hot ready
blue 0 BL it hot ready blue 80 BL it hot
I not snap pton Manning was the best at
that man I thought Dan Marino was he's
hey hey that that's that's a blast from
the past I didn't I didn't I don't know
if they were miked up when Dan Marino
was you didn't need to be you could you
could hear him because he would be like
he'd just go up there and
goes yes like I don't even know what
that's on if you're a lineman or
something and you're like okay is it on
three is it two is but he would
go and that's what dak's doing now here
you go I've never heard of that in my
life but it's like go go most viral
thing yeah good St all these all these
quarterbacks are different man all right
yeah crazy uh Chase Daniel you can see
his show on YouTube channel the Chase
Daniel show and uh Hey thank you again
uh all your help this year and uh we'll
talk to you in the new year uh Merry
Christmas to you bud Merry Christmas
guys that's Chase Daniel always
interesting always good stuff